I'm going to start with the most
important question up front when
Universal and Chris Nolan came to you
and said we want to make a sequel to The
Adjustment Bureau but we want to call it
Oppenheimer and B and it's going to be
about Robert Oppenheimer but it's really
a sequel to The Adjustment Bureau we
were like wait you can't go through
doors in Oppenheimer with your Fedora
you didn't wear a fedora yeah and then
then it said I wasn't wearing he wore
the Fedora yeah right thank you for my
students so listen I'm a fan of both of
your Works uh and there's gonna be a lot
of people out there who have actually
never seen anything you've done before
uh for someone who's never seen anything
what's the first thing you'd like them
watching and why Oppenheimer
really I mean this is this is a really
um it's it's the biggest story of our
lives and of the last maybe of the in
the history of the human species so far
and uh told by a director who's at the
absolute top of his game and
um with one of the great screen
performances at the center of it and so
Chris always said to us when we were
making it like this is you know I need
you guys in support that's the mission
basically is the supporting Killian this
whole movie hinges on that performance
um It's gotta be it will it'll resonate
emotionally if that if we're with that
character he wrote the script in the
first person which I'd never seen before
so instead of saying Oppenheimer walked
across the room it's I walk across the
room and you know and so it's like it
just it had that it just it just ripped
you into that world and
um and with given what's at stake like
there's not a more important story out
there agreed
agreed I'm sorry you can answer the next
question what's your next question uh I
am curious you guys obviously read a lot
of scripts and you get offered a lot of
roles what is it like when Chris calls
you or texts you you just say whatever
you want whatever you need do you need
me to say aligned you want me to do
catering like what do you need from me
and it's so pulse racing when you know
he wants to meet you it's the best
feeling ever because
he's so extraordinary like he's of such
vast talent and ability you know you're
going to be a part of a film that is
lasting in whatever capacity that is and
so I was thrilled to meet him and
yeah he's just a cool guy as well you
could kind of talk to him we talked for
hours even before he gave me the script
and I went to his living room and I read
the script and then we talked more
afterwards
and I think that's what I love most
about him the Curiosity in the process
the passion for it the passion for
actors and
what you need and to take away all the
chaos from you even though I'm sure to
keep all the plates in the air shooting
a film of this scale he must have had
endless plates in the air you must have
had a hurricane going on inside of him
throughout the whole process I just
don't feel it you don't feel it you
don't you feel this Focus this beautiful
master class all the time because he
wants to create an environment even at
that scale of Storytelling where you can
you're free creatively to to come up
with your best ideas and and to kind of
put them out there and it there's no
rigidity to the way he would think with
that much going on that you know he
would say well say your line here and
cross over to there and and there's none
of that my favorite is how English he is
when he's happy you know it's my
favorite he's like yeah good happy yeah
okay moving on that's good and you're
just like was it good you know that's
Chris at his happy yeah by the way
exactly you know you
scene went well you mentioned it already
how you read the script in his living
room and I know he asks people to come
to his house to read the script what is
it actually like for you sitting in his
house reading the script knowing he's in
the other room waiting for you to finish
well he in my case he actually came this
is kind of a funny story he came to my
apartment here in New York and I live in
the same apartment building as Emma and
so he came because he's you know he had
a reason to be a New York personal
reason to be in New York City because
I'm going to come over and I'm going to
bring you the script so I said great so
he comes over and we talk and it's a
Friday night and and it's getting late
and he says so you're going to read this
tomorrow morning and I said yes he said
what time and I said I'll read it at
nine he said how long will it take you
and I go I read it uh exactly at the
same Pace the movie will play and he
goes I'll be here at noon and I said
okay so it turns out we came to find out
later that he knew he wanted Emily in
that part and me and my part but he
didn't want to offer her the part at the
same apartment building on the same day
because he didn't want
he pretended that he didn't and then he
called her a few days later and said oh
would you like to because she was in LA
she happened to be in L.A I'm busy would
you like to come over and read the
scripture
so it was uh it was very funny but I was
I I think I was probably nervous reading
it at first thinking am I going to be
behind the physics and the science am I
going to be able to wrap my head around
all of it and then you realize that is
the backdrop that is not the full thrust
of the script that's not what's so pulse
racing about it it was such an emotional
script to read and it's really about the
trauma of this of living with a brain
like that and then the ramifications of
what that brain brought to the world
um and but I knew he would come in
the worst thing is when you read a
script and you have to perform your your
love of it there's none of that with
Chris you don't have to nothing's
performative ever because of what he
creates is so extraordinary so he came
in and I just said my I'm Hearts racing
I said I feel like my whole body's on
fire reading this script
and you don't have to perform it because
it is I saw the film last night in IMAX
70 millimeter at the Lincoln Square
Theater uh it is I mean there's no words
for that presentation have you guys seen
it in IMAX seven days oh yeah yeah yeah
and what is it can you watch yourselves
on screen or you can get a little
tweaked out by it I mean I don't
sometimes I do if I think the film's not
very good but but I think
I felt this was like a full kidnap this
one I just felt I thought my bones were
going to shatter I felt this like weight
on my breastplate the whole way through
it and you feel like you're inside of it
you feel like you're inside of it so I
think we're all sort of lost for words
afterwards it was emotional I watched it
with Robert and we were both really
emotional watching it yeah and I had her
and I had spoken to Emily because she
saw it before I did and uh and so I was
kind of prepared for that so I didn't
think about watching we couldn't stop
talking to you about it could we we were
just yeah no I mean on and on it's it's
a heart it's hard to stop talking about
it's really
yeah you know I mean it's it's really
something oh completely and uh the shame
is it's only I think 30-something
theaters around the world that can show
it in the max 70. yeah but I'm just
saying for people watching this for the
love of God please please
it's what it was he sweat bullets to
make it in IMAX well they invented black
and white IMAX film for the movie oh
this movie 100 yeah so I want to
actually specifically ask about working
with the IMAX cameras because what is it
like when you're next to one of these
it's a beast of a camera
yes what is it actually like working
with one of those and it's so expensive
every shot yeah yeah but you know you're
you're kind of insulated from that side
of it you know I'm sure Emma you know is
as a producer is probably much more
aware of that than yeah than the actors
are but um but it was like at the
beginning of my career movie cameras
were quite big and I remember having to
kind of in my in my teens and early 20s
having to think about technically trying
to assimilate that into my process and
then everything kind of got easier the
light you know either the cameras if
you're working on dig which Chris never
does but but they're much more light
sensitive so there's less gear now but
in general the cameras are different
there's less gear so going back to IMAX
kind of didn't it felt like at the
beginning of my career it didn't it
didn't feel very it doesn't feel
obtrusive it's one of the really really
loud so I think
um you just know that it's not going to
be a take where they'll use the sound
that you did but then Chris will sort of
pre-record it he'll use a different take
where
you can use the same dialogue within the
IMAX frame as well so he's he tries to
do everything in camera you don't want
to be adring stuff but I think you get
that sense because hoita I don't know
how he slings that IMAX camera on his
shoulder without breaking his back but
he does
and because hoita is so sort of
sensitive to the processes where you
stop noticing him you don't notice Chris
who's always standing and he's always
standing right next to the camera just
watching you the way the old school like
it's what Coppola told me years ago he
said that's what Antonio said to him he
said you sit next to your operator you
look at it with your naked eye and when
you're done you don't understand in some
ways because there's so much Focus but
also they're kind of with you you're
kind of there in a group talking anyway
and then suddenly Hoyts has got the
camera on his you know what I mean it
feels so intimate
um even though it's at this massive
scale they somehow managed to make it
feel so relaxed yeah it's really
something that note I need to go I
really want to say sincere
congratulations incredible